[Musique]
depuis maintenant un mois le métro
parisien n'est plus nettoyées dans
certaines stations on assiste à la
prolifération des rats des souris et
même des vers de terre les grévistes
s'opposent à tout nettoyage effectué à
la sauvette et d'une manière générale
les 900 balayeur du métro en très grande
majorité des immigrés semble prêt à
s'installer dans une grève très dure à
reportage de dominique torrès et alain
129 jours de grève pour les nettoyeurs
du métro après trois semaines les
grévistes ont obtenu l'autorisation de
se servir des douches et de la cantine
du personnel de la ratp des locaux dont
ils effectuent d'ailleurs le nettoyage
les quatorze employeurs qui sous traite
à la ratp ont accepté de passer les
nettoyants du métro de 2330 les semis à
2600 francs par mois et pour l'instant
les grévistes d'yvel et peu très peu
comment vivez vous parce que c'est
comment on ne part la mairie mairie vous
donnez des safrans
chaque semaine 200 francs deschamps
france excellent même si ça convient et
vivait que sur ça c'est sa cellule avec
des familles parfois avec des femmes est
très difficile très dur très dur et si
vraiment madame on amarre le bloc après
29 jours de grève
nous avons entamé les négociations avec
les patrons du nettoyage est
actuellement sur les 500 francs que
demandent les travailleurs pour arriver
à 2800 francs aux nets par mois
les patrons n'ont accordé actuellement
que 191 3 avec qui exactement négocier
vous concernant les conditions de
travail il m'a garanti de l'emploi nous
avons négocié avec la direction de la
ratp c'est problème la concerne elle
maintenant sur les salaires nous
négocions avec les quatorze patrons des
entreprises du métro et en présence de
la direction de les rater
selon vo qui tient les ficelles dans
cette lutte les patrons une part de
responsabilité mais la direction de la
ratp doivent tirer les ficelles canal
aussi bien le personnel de la ratp pour
les usagers semblent en général
favorable à cause des grévistes mais au
point de vue le savez il ya pas de
raison laissant juste le raison parce
que vivre avec ce qu'ils veulent c'est
terriblement difficile il faut quand
même pas exagérer non plus et un jury
lui s'en prend par mois c'est pas la mer
à boire de ce qu'ils demandent
qu'est-ce qui est pas normal devrait
être augmenté ça vous trouvez qu'ils ont
raison ah oui j'ai raison vous les
soutenez alors bien sûr
c'est normal mais qui suit même si vous
avez des inconvénients dans la sphère
des inconvénients d'en haut pour vous
pour vous usagers du métro mais c'est
normal c'est obligé le métro va être
augmenté eux seront augmentés c'est
normal êtes au courant des
revendications des nettoyeurs du métro
ne vous est pas intéressé écoutez je
n'ai pas le droit de m'intéresser à ça
j'arrive de province je m'en vais au
travail
j'avais toujours rêvé le taxi c'est très
désagréable pour le public
évidemment cela
alors place à présent le conflit se
poursuit pour 200 francs de plus par
mois la ratp refuse de fléchir et les
ouvriers tiennent bon il souligne que
même avec les 2830 qu'il réclame ils
seront encore payer moins beaucoup moins
pour les éboueurs de la capitale qui
sont considérés eux comme des
fonctionnaires à part entière
[Musique]